[Music]
there is a comic where Darth Vader
fights Darth Maul and it's amazing so
this comic takes place before the events
of episode 4 when Darth Vader's on the
hunt for the battle plans for the first
Death Star which were stolen by the
Rebel Alliance and the idea is that this
is seemingly the place where the Rebel
Alliance is hanging out at at least
that's the information he had been given
now of course we know that's not the
case but he sends the Stormtroopers out
to do what Stormtroopers do which is
usually just gets shot up destroyed or
miss their target every time they pull
the trigger but somebody out there is
literally going through and just killing
every single Stormtrooper they come
across now what's crazy about this is
Darth Vader figures out incredibly fast
that the Rebel Alliance is not here but
instead of simply just leaving he
actually just kind of explores the place
for a moment and in fact he opens the
temple using the power of the force
right like one of the Stormtroopers is
like do you want us to blow the doors
open and Darth Vader's like nope that
won't be necessary I got Force Power so
on and opens the door up right now as he
makes his way through there these
Stormtroopers kind of provide a little
bit of context to this place because
Darth Vader makes the statement that
this place is very strong with the dark
side and that's when he kind of realizes
the Rebel Alliance isn't here but one of
the Storm Troopers makes this statement
and saying if the rebels are here they
could not have picked a spookier place
and when one of the guys starts talking
about the history of it he says a
hundred years ago in Aristocrat named
Baron Yorn left Coruscant and came here
with some followers they believed the
moon was a focal point for the dark side
of the force so they built this Fortress
with the intention of conducting
experiments to explore the dark side but
something happened when the supply ship
returned all of them had vanished except
for Yorn who'd gone mad and tore out his
eyes and his own tongue so it's like a
really twisted place now as an aside in
Star Wars there's all kinds of planets
and locations out there that are very
strong in the light and the dark side of
the force we've learned that over the
course of the entirety of the expanded
universe when it existed but what ends
up happening with one of these
Stormtroopers is they literally get
Force choked and he kind of makes this
statement and saying like we apologize
like it was just idle talk please don't
kill me but that's when Vader's like
this is not my doing I'm not the one
who's killing you guys so he breaks out
his lightsaber and says like show
yourself and that's when these three
beings kind of come out of nowhere and
what they do is they call him into
question right you've been measured
you've been tested and you've been found
wanting the idea here is that they want
to kill off Darth Vader and they want to
replace him with Darth Maul as the
proper Apprentice of Darth Sidious now
here's the thing to understand about
Darth Maul if you go and you read his
comics of course Vader You could argue
is more powerful than Darth Maul Anakin
in his normal human form certainly was
right that's without question but the
kicker here is that there is a school of
thought out there that Darth Maul was a
better Apprentice for darcitius than
Anakin Skywalker was because unlike
Anakin Skywalker who fell to the dark
side more out of a desire to save Padme
Darth Maul was just pure hatred
incarnate right this guy was like people
on Twitter he was mad about everything
so it's just one of those crazy things
where people are like it was a mistake
to have Vader become the new Apprentice
for Sidious instead of Darth Maul now
not everybody believes that and I
imagine the number of people who do is
very very small but this group here
looks at him and says you're more
machine than man you're not actually a
person who's fit to be a Apprentice for
Darth Sidious Darth Maul should be that
guy instead now Darth Vader takes this
as a personal upfront and he tells them
like you bring Doom upon yourselves
right that's going to be important here
in a little while I want you to keep
that in the back of your heads but when
he goes to attack them Darth Maul steps
in now it totally blows Darth Vader her
away he never saw this coming right he's
like Darth Maul like you should be dead
now one of the things to know and this
is kind of where you get into murky
territory does Darth Vader really
remember things with Darth Maul even
when he's entering into the temple
itself he talks about how he senses the
presence that's familiar but it's not
really the same way as it was with like
Obi-Wan Kenobi because in a new hope he
says like I sense a presence that I
haven't felt in a long time so there's
no real indication that he remembers
everything with Darth Maul which kind of
makes sense because he was so young and
Darth Maul was killed long before Anakin
became a proper Apprentice or really a
proper Padawan to Obi-Wan Kenobi but the
fight between the two this is what I'm
curious about man I want to know how you
guys think this fight would have gone
right like in reality outside of this
comic who do you think would have
actually won now Darth Vader asked the
question how have you done this right
they don't give him an answer but what
he does say is like Darth Maul was slain
years ago so there's no possible way he
can be alive here and the only thing
they really do is they say there are
ways to create an individual to mold an
individual in every way if the hate is
strong enough we took it upon ourselves
to resurrect a proper Apprentice for the
master rather than tolerate one who is
Tainted but we've not really given a
proper explanation in terms of how they
do it honestly we could simply just say
it's Sith Alchemy it's one of the cool
things about the entirety of the Sith
history that in a lot of ways Disney
doesn't really explore too much because
you can do some crazy stuff with the
force if you know what you're doing
right you can just do Bonkers things
resurrecting people from the dead and so
on and so forth more than just like some
dubious statement made by Sidious to
Anakin Skywalker in order to convince
him to fall to the dark side I mean like
legit resurrecting people from the dead
it's nuts but the whole idea here is
they want the two of them to fight to
the death now initially Darth Vader
intends to walk away but what they say
say is Darth Maul will prove himself by
slaying you the emperor will be pleased
of course you could refuse the duel and
attempt to destroy all of us here and
now you might even succeed but such a
deed would diminish you in the emperor's
eyes would it not and you would always
wonder doubt would always nag at you you
could never be certain whether Darth
Maul was your better unless you take up
this challenge so let's see what you
have to offer and the fight between the
two is cool because honestly they're
right even though Palpatine has somewhat
of a role in this we'll actually find
out more as we get towards the end of
this story if Darth Vader had refused
the duel and Palpatine had learned that
this duel could have happened Palpatine
probably would have started plotting to
replace Darth Vader because remember
when it comes to the rule of the Sith
that the goal of The Apprentice is to
basically become strong enough and kill
the master but by passing up an
opportunity to even potentially even
expand their skills it would would show
the emperor that Darth Vader is falling
short of his role as a Sith and so he
fights Darth Maul now the fight between
the two is awesome because Darth Maul
talks like the most trash ever right
like you are a sham you're a Jedi I can
see it in you alone light in the
darkness that you refuse to extinguish
you're nothing like me my darkness my
hatred is unending right and so like
Darth Vader tries to counter as best he
can in terms of like talking trash but
let's be honest man Darth Vader is good
at being intimidating but if you read
the Star Wars comics Darth Maul dude
this guy's ability to trash talk is like
his number one power forget his ability
to like duel with a lightsaber in his
command over the force man his trash
talk is on a whole nother level and so
one of the things that happens here is
that as they're dueling back and forth
Darth Vader says I don't need help to
destroy an imposter and the response of
Darth Maul is it's you who wears the
mask you who hides his unworthiness tell
me which of us is truly an imposter now
one of the cool things that Darth Maul
picks up on here is there is that small
glint of light that's inside Darth Vader
we know that from the Darth Vader solo
Series where he actually goes to visit
the burial right like the tomb of Padme
so he hasn't quite let that go we know
that from like the Return of the Jedi
when he turns back to the Light Side
there's just that little part of him
that hasn't completely Fallen he's like
the Kel dromas right falling to the dark
side going back to the Light Side
repenting for his actions that kind of
thing and so one of the things that
happens is in this fight between the two
of them Darth Vader's able to hold his
own now this is the reason why I say
there's no way that Darth Maul would
have stood a chance against Anakin
Skywalker in like Star Wars episode
three he would have sliced this guy to
ribbons and been home in time for corn
flakes but with Darth Vader it's a
little bit different because sure it's
still Anakin Skywalker but he's slower
than he was before he's not as agile as
he was before but I would argue his
command over the force is greater than
it was before the potential was always
there but in lieu of being able to be as
agile as he was he had to compensate for
it focusing more on his ability to
manipulate the force that's really where
Darth Vader's strength shows itself so
even when you have Darth Maul who's
bouncing around and dancing around and
so on and so forth even while he's
talking trash and saying like surprising
Jedi you stand your ground against me I
wonder are you as confident when you
can't depend upon the ground beneath you
and he takes out the entirety of the
ground under Vader Vader's still able to
bounce back he's still able to recover
from that fall now some of that's also
because he's just a giant lug of a
machine right but still the response of
maul is did you learn nothing from the
master never break a fall if you are
prepared to break your fall you are
prepared for the fall itself and then he
says Sith do not fall there is no pain
where strength lies and the only real
response that Vader gives is someone
taught you your lessons well not as well
as I learned mod and so that's where you
start to see how Vader shines and is
more capable than Darth Maul Darth Maul
had command over the force and he can do
some cool stuff with the force but I
would argue Darth Maul's command and his
use of the force is nowhere near what
Vader's is when you're fighting Darth
Vader you're not just fighting a Sith
Lord with a lightsaber you're fighting
your entire environment everything
becomes a weapon everything becomes
something that can kill you and so the
only counter the Darth Maul gives here
is he's effectively running away is
follow me if you can and of course Vader
follows him now these guys who are
watching this battle come to realize
they're a lot more evenly matched right
Vader and mall are a lot more evenly
matched than they expected them to to be
there's still the belief that Darth Maul
will be victorious that he's an engine
of pure hate but that Darth Vader
there's too much of the light side in
him but one of the things they seem to
fail to to realize here Darth Vader was
born of the force so that's one of the
reasons why you see a lot of fans in the
Star Wars Mythos who look at Anakin
Skywalker and argue had he never fallen
to the dark side had he stayed Anakin
Skywalker and potentially even stayed on
the light path right meaning that he
actually joined Mace Windu and killed
Emperor Palpatine assuming he didn't
like run off with Padme and abandon the
Jedi or whatever he'd be the most
powerful Jedi to ever exist in the
history of Star Wars some would argue he
already was right it just kind of
depends on who you're talking to but the
fact remains here that Darth Vader being
as capable as he is is being painfully
overlooked and that's kind of the big
failure of the Sith in a lot of ways
sure they're cooler than the Jedi they
always have been and they always will be
and do not listen to anyone who tells
you otherwise the Sith are definitely
cooler than the Jedi but in a lot of
ways while they chastised the Jedi for
being so hyper focused on meditation and
just kind of sitting around in their
Citadel you know smoking hashish and
talking about like what they should do
and meditating on the force and whatnot
the Sith aren't really all that
different they focus so much on rage
they focus so much on passion because
where the Jedi see peace and kind of a
personal Attunement with the force as
their source of power and the Sith see
emotions as their source of power
they're not that different when it comes
to those two groups right the only real
differentiation between whether the Sith
or the Jedi come out on top is how well
one side's able to trick the other and
so Darth Maul literally says like now
we'll finish this and the response of
Vader is yes we will finish this and so
the response them all here he says how
can you be a fit servant for the master
you're more machine than man how could a
machine hate and that's what I'm talking
about here so much emphasis being put on
emotion there's so little understanding
of how you can actually blend the light
side and the dark side becoming
something akin to a gray Jedi and come
out on top of course Darth Vader is not
a great Jedi the dude's a straight up
Sith Lord but the fact remains here that
like having facing off against someone
like Vader being hyper focused on the
fact that he's more machine than man and
seeing that as a weakness is overlooking
the inherent nature of Darth Vader a
being born of the force fighting the
very nature of the force itself and so
even in this instance when he says how
will you defeat me I slew Obi-Wan
Kenobi's master the response of Vader is
an Obi-Wan Kenobi killed you right so
the transitive property here there's no
way you're stronger than me that kind of
thing because he killed Obi-Wan Kenobi
right so the battle between them is like
just to the death and it's hardcore now
initially he gets the upper hand right
Maul gets the upper hand on Vader
slashes his helmet and says now your
master will have an apprentice worthy of
the Sith but what he ends up doing here
is actually not paying attention to
what's going on around him because he
says no Jedi fire for you Skywalker your
hate was not nearly enough and where he
basically knocks the lightsaber out of
his hands Darth Vader does the one thing
that Darth Maul would never have done he
intentionally injures himself to injure
his opponent he recalls his lightsaber
back to him and then activates it stabs
through himself and then stabs through
Darth Maul like literally Darth Maul is
like what what could you hate enough in
order to destroy me and the response of
Vader myself I hate myself more than
anything else now that's one of the most
important things to understand about
Darth Vader's character it's been true
ever since his character was introduced
in Star Wars itself if there's any one
person that Darth Vader hates the most
it is himself he despises himself
because of how easily he was tempted to
the dark side in hindsight how silly it
was to believe that a being out there
right a guy Lord Sidious whose entire
group The Sith are known for being
duplicitous known for being Liars right
manipulators that he would believe him
when he says we can find a way to save
Padme how could someone be so foolish
but being so caught up in Emotion being
so swept up in the fact that it was
possible not even sitting down and
considering the fact whether it could
actually be done ultimately got the
better of him and he's hitted himself
ever since because Darth Vader You could
argue is single-handedly responsible for
the collapse of the Republic and so it's
a really cool Revelation here because
Darth Vader comes out on top and Darth
Vader killed Darth Maul and so what you
end up having is him showing up to these
guys and saying you bring this Doom upon
your ourselves only for them to be
destroyed by Emperor Palpatine using
forced lightning and he says I see you
have survived Apprentice good now one of
the coolest things about city is when it
comes to like the comics and even in
like the movies and the TV shows it's
very very mysterious in terms of what he
does did he have a hand in this or did
he not right that he asked him like how
did you come to be here and his response
is my shuttle followed yours Lord Vader
I'd hoped you would be retrieving those
stolen Plans by the rebels am I to
assume the plans are not here right he's
like nope it was all a deception that
was perpetrated by those that you just
slew a deception designed to draw me to
this place and where Vader says they had
recreated Darth Maul I don't know how
the response of Sidious is there are
ways that those who are no more can live
again they were Heretics these three
apparently they believed they could
provide me with a superior Apprentice
yet you are victorious and so when Vader
asks him was any of this known to you
what these acolytes were attempting his
response is no but it's darcidious so
there's no reason to believe that this
wasn't all a giant ruse by him to test
Darth Vader and that if Vader failed
that Maul would return as his Apprentice
there's no definitive answer there right
but I want to know what you guys think
do you guys think that Darth Vader in
his current form would actually defeat
Darth Maul or do you think that Darth
Maul would have killed Vader here with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching now we'll catch you all later
peace